a true sci-fi classic is about to get a
sequel hopefully welcome to sidetrack
your sci-fi tv a movie channel
[Music]
so the last starfighter is one of those
properly classic sci-fi movies it was
actually really really clever in the way
it was made it was one of the earliest
movies along with maybe tron to use real
life sort of cgi within the movie they
actually had a really really good an
interesting plot and characters it was a
really memorable movie and they've been
trying to get a sequel or a reboot for
decades but actually it finally looks
like it's going to happen and
most beautifully and most happily of all
it will not be a reboot but a proper
sequel so what do we know so far
well this actually isn't new news but i
do have a source that has been able to
add a little bit of information to what
is already out there i'll tell you a
little bit about that in a minute but
what do we know actually at the moment
gary witter is the screenwriter that is
um putting together the script for the
sequel and he has said in a couple of
interviews in the last month or so that
they are very very close that they are
in the final one-yard dash of actually
getting this green lit
i'll tell you a bit more about what i
now know that to me uh in a couple of
minutes but the thing that's really
interesting about this is jonathan
bitchwell who wrote the actual original
script has done a little bit of work
with gary on this and they've actually
created this um little short video that
they released on youtube
now that video shows the little bits of
artwork and concept art from their
planned script one of the most
interesting things about that little
video they put together is that the gun
star actually looks virtually the same
as the original gun starts almost
identical
i really like that and i really think
that that's important for a sequel like
this when you've got such an iconic ship
as the gun stop
to have it the same and not to
re-modernize it and let's be honest ruin
it
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
track and hit the join button all these
little things they really help me to
keep the channel going in and in those
few little pennies that basically means
the wife will let me keep doing it he's
not the only person from the original
project actually to be talking about
this though nick castle in an interview
from april actually said he's been
hearing some really promising whispers
about this sequel and that it actually
is got a really good chance of getting
made when people like gary witter start
talking about the new project and trying
to get it off the ground i'd listen i'm
interested but when people from the
original project start saying that they
think this is actually going to happen
then my ears do prick and i do start
having a proper listen because this does
feel like this is something that's about
to get announced and if this really does
get made and universal does push forward
with this project we might get to see
the last starfighters on the silver
screen but why is this a movie i want to
see well the last starfighter from 1984
was one of those classic sci-fi movies
where the special effects actually were
jaw-dropping back in the day um you know
remembering what computer games were
like at the time this was just
phenomenal it actually had a really
interesting not overly complicated but
interesting story i liked characters
like the beta character now they did
that this this android that took alex's
place back on earth while he was off
training to become the last starfighter
i like those little bits of information
like that i love the centauri character
um you know that cheeky con man sort of
character that was just really
interesting and i love how he'd put the
training simulator this arcade game on
earth and actually then got in trouble
for it the whole movie was really full
of fascinating characters i have to
admit the
bad guy was a bit ridiculous with his
thing with it and all that stuff but i
thought that was a bit much i didn't
never really thought he was scary i did
think the chord on empire were really
the villains in that series but they had
to have uh rylan inside or supposed to
to make the whole plot about the last
star fighter and the destruction of the
other gun stars make sense
but the main reason why i want to see
this film get made
is the gun star itself
every so often in sci-fi
you get
designs for ships that you just look at
and just go that could work that look
real and and i think that realism draws
you into the fantasy even more because
you think this my god this could happen
this could be real and that just
adds that little bit of realism to it i
think there's a similar thing with
stargate compared to star trek that star
trek is fantasy stargate definitely sg-1
etcetera could be real there could be a
gate under cheyenne mountain and that
like makes it more exciting for some
reason and the last starfighter has the
same sort of thing going on for it the
gun star with its engines is a very
different sort of design those things
that the front points that was are
actual thrusters that mean it can stop
suddenly and there is just as big as a
thrust as the propeller that is
realistic in space that actually to stop
to actually make a spacecraft go
forwards you actually don't need that
much momentum once it's got it going to
a certain speed it'll just keep flying
at that speed forever but the thing is
you need equal force to then stop it
so actually your engines facing forwards
should be as big as your engines facing
backwards but you never see that in
sci-fi it also had lots and lots of
thrusters that mean it could spin and do
all sorts yeah when it does the death
blossom maneuver which again i just
freaking loved
um
the ship design with a gunner and a
pilot again
makes sense from a fighting point of
view
especially when you're considering
shooting at a three-dimensional sphere
of influence that the gunner would
actually be just as important as the
pilot so that is the main reason why i
want to see this film get made because i
want to see the gun star fly again but
where were we at the end of the movie
and what does it mean potentially for a
sequel which actually
gary witter has said on more than one
occasion this film will be a sequel not
a reboot a reboot has been considered in
the past but isn't going to happen for
the moment well
alex and maggie at the end of the
original movie did go off back into
space
maybe they're now
higher up generals within the ryan star
league or something along that nature
you know we could actually see them
being a mentor for the new batch of star
fighters i should say that in the little
teaser reel that we've seen it looks
like there are going to be six
starfighters in this one they are not
going to be the last starfighters is
going to be a small group of about six
of them
how much you want to bet they make them
young cadets again
it's going to happen isn't it
but it would be interesting to have alex
in some sort of role along that as a
mentor or something that maybe come back
as a centauri type character
so
what do you do when you are editing a
video and you suddenly realize that you
forgot to give the lovely viewers the
bit of information you'd be given the
whole reason for doing the video in the
first place
you get your phone you go upstairs and
you
do the videos an additional and hope
that no one notices
so the bit of information about the last
star fighter that i've been told
so i have sources that work in and
around this industry um they have
feed me bits of information from here
and there and the one person i've spoken
to has said
they work within um a field working 3d
modelers he's actually a three model
himself but he works within a company
that does
and they have recently done 3d modeling
work on the last starfighter so they
have actually done a 3d model a cgi
version of the gunstar
now they say that that is quite an
expensive thing to do
um it is in the tens of thousands of
dollars so he believes this would not be
done unless the gun star was about to
appear in a major project hopefully a
motion picture
um and this is one more sign that this
is actually pretty close to getting
green lit
now all i have to do is actually make
sure to remember to actually add this
bit of information to the video instead
of getting overly excited and just talk
about the gun star for 10 minutes
because it's my favorite sci-fi ship or
definitely up there in the top five
what is it
but there we go
one more piece of information that just
leads me
genuinely to believe this is a project
that might get green lit
very soon
so please guys get into the comments
tell me exactly what you think is this a
project that you are excited to see do
you want to see the gun star fly again
if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe and hit the bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you've enjoyed the content consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged sidetracker as always
please stay safe i'll see you next time
reading starfighter
you have been recruited by the star
league to defend the frontier against
sewer and the kodan armada get ready
prepare for blasto
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you